I want to dig in a little more into the
sort of psychology of the Donald Trump
vote-rigging election-rigging claims
I've told you many times now we've
talked about it for a while that Donald
Trump is claiming that if he loses the
election is rigged was rigged he was
asked at the third and final
presidential debate here in Las Vegas
Nevada couple days ago whether he will
accept the results of the election no
matter who wins and he said he's not
going to commit to that ahead of time
that he's going to wait to see what the
results are and and then sort of decide
and he's continued these charges he has
when asked well specifically what
element of the election is rigged
sometimes he says the rigging is that
there's dead people millions of dead
people on the voter rolls were voting
and for some reason he thinks they're
voting for Hillary Clinton uh other
times he said the media favoring Hillary
Clinton is the way in which the election
is rigged now of course that's not
rigging an election those are
allegations of media bias but it's not
rigging an election at the debate two
nights ago he said while the rigging is
Hillary Clinton shouldn't even be
allowed to run because she's guilty of a
crime so the mere fact that she's a
candidate is evidence that the election
is rigged whatever explanation you want
to focus in on here's the question I
want to discuss today are Donald Trump's
allegations of a rigged election
actually hurting himself by focusing in
his own electorate on the idea that
whether they vote or not Hillary Clinton
is going to win anyway and as I started
to think about it I thought okay well
let's see hillary clinton voters by and
large don't seem to think that the
election is rigged so when hillary
clinton rebukes Trump and says you're
really attacking American democracy at
its core by saying this is a rigged
election etc Hillary Clinton's voters
are not going to say oh it's not even
worth voting now they're hearing what
Hillary Clinton says and to most of them
it sounds like a reasonable response to
trumps claims of a rigged election and
they're going to go vote but it's
possible particular
when you look at the nut low-information
of reality of so many Trump supporters
if they hear their own candidate say
millions of dead people are voting this
entire thing is rigged it was rigged
against Bernie Sanders during the
democratic primary and the media is
rigging it and Hillary's guilty and it's
already in the tank for Hillary Clinton
maybe if you're a trump supporter
particularly one who maybe hasn't voted
before and you're voting specifically
because of Donald Trump embolden you in
some way maybe you say you know what
it's not even really worth voting
because after all even the guy I like is
saying that this is rigged I don't know
that trumps staffers have been doing a
great job of handling this issue some
have just said it's not rigged period
and Republican governor secretaries of
state etcetera have said it's not rigged
Trump's campaign manager Kellyanne
Conway was on multiple morning shows the
day before the day after the last
presidential debate she said it was just
too early to say whether voting
irregularities could make a difference
between winning and losing the
presidential race then in a separate
interview on Fox News Channel she said
that Donald Trump has been reading
stories about voting irregularities so
that the entire thing is not without any
basis up to thoughts on this number one
it's more dangerous for Trump to talk
about a rigged election because it's his
voters that might not show up to the
polls if they actually believe that
their vote won't matter won't be counted
whatever uh and number two I also think
it's important to note that if indeed
Donald Trump loses it's not going to be
because of some voting irregularities in
just a couple of states it's very
possible if you look at the polling if
you look at the electoral vote numbers
looking at state-by-state polling this
could be such a major defeat for Donald
Trump that the idea that some quote vote
rigging in some states turned the
election altogether the numbers most
likely are not even going to make that a
viable argument
I think that Donald Trump is either in
denial about that or just not thinking
about the repercussions